this not human was recovered from the
site redacted precious not human mouth
anomalous object AO 1504 w GG y x JK
item description an unremarkable man who
is not able to be harmed native recovery
location of recovery current status
AO 1504 is held in a standard humanoid
containment cell which has been stricken
from the document and replaced with
missing
addendum 1504 - one interviewed AO 1504
interviewer dr. Lloyd forward AO 1504 is
being questioned on its background
playing log now what is your name I
don't remember Joe something okay now
what year were you born
1982 thank you for the year but do you
have an exact date no I never knew when
I was born oh excuse me my nose is
bleeding
I'm sorry that was weird I've never been
prone to random nosebleeds it's fine
maybe a storm is coming
I've heard the changing air pressure can
make a person's nose bleed maybe do you
know why you can't be hurt I don't
really want to talk about that's fine
thank you for your cooperation with
today's interview you may return to your
room
addendum 1504 - - I didn't know his true
anomaly we didn't know what he'd really
do I guess he affects computers - our
automatic security system began to have
hiccups a breach here a breach there but
nothing that surprised us but then our
Keter got out only about half of the
staff here realized it the other half
all died we managed to contain it
we sent a request for more staff but
they never responded our supplies were
dwindling so we asked for more nothing
they didn't even acknowledge our
existence we had more breaches more
deaths yet we never questioned these
breaches or these deaths I don't know
why we didn't question those deaths
earlier today we had a site-wide
containment breach all the doors opened
because of those hiccups I mentioned
earlier most of the remaining staff
members are dead those who are still
alive are few and far between
we can't contain a breach of this
magnitude all of their foundation sites
will probably ignore it they'll cite it
as completely normal and ignore it put
this in the vault and set off the
on-site nuke I'm already badly hurt and
the blast would save more lives than it
will end if anyone ever finds this tell
my wife that I love her and I'm sorry
for spending so much time in my job tell
her that I said goodbye that I'm
thinking of her as I died this is a
researcher Dowell Lloyd signing up
addendum 1504 - 3 the site nuclear
warhead was detonated on to counteract a
class 7 containment breach a total of
anomalies were destroyed in the blast
anomalies were recovered and the
nominees are missing including al 1504
and foundation personnel died inside
this document has the updated bernabéu
information recovered from piper enacted
item number SCP 1504 object class
Keter special containment procedures SCP
1504 is not currently contained if any
foundation personnel see the subject
they are to contact the current project
head in the event SCP 1504 is found it
is to be brought to area 114 and
contained in a three by three by three
meter containment chamber do you enter
the subjects containment chamber a total
of four level three staff members are
needed two staff members must remain
inside the control room to remotely
enact the failsafe should a containment
breach occur the failsafe consists of
flooding the containment chamber and
surrounding areas with halo thane vapor
which is proven to be the only viable
method to incapacitate SCP 15:04 viable
method to incapacitate SCP 1504 was
stricken from the document extensive
research has shown that SCP 1504 can be
incapacitated by blunt force trauma to
the head the subject is to be kept fully
confined and incapacitated at all times
through the use of restraints and
halothane vapor other staff members must
release multiple locks simultaneously a
minimum of four guards are to be
protecting them at this time after all
locks are released one staff member may
enter the containment chamber the guards
must be ready for a containment breach
at all times in a containment chamber is
open no automatic systems may be used in
area 114 all doors and containers must
be locked
using simple combination locks or simple
padlocks all personnel working at area
114 must have a high aptitude for
parapsychology or a strong resilience to
perception shifts
description SCP 1504 is a Caucasian male
standing at 1.95 meters tall
the subjects appearances unremarkable
aside from a small birthmark on its
right shoulder SCP 1504 s anomalous
traits include its inability to be
harmed or killed all actions carried out
by NCP 1504 will be perceived by
surrounding individuals as being within
expectations for the situation as CP
1504 has been known to attack personnel
who will then believe circumstance or
their own doing has hurt them the
subject is able to affect electronic and
automatic systems SCP 1504 was brought
to the attention of the foundation
because of its inability to be harmed
and was classified as an anomalous
object after initial testing the subject
was held at site in the anomalous object
wing of the facility a site-wide
security failure and subsequent
containment breach resulted in the
on-site nuclear warhead being detonated
SCP 1504 was declared missing after a
search of the site did not reveal a
confirmed death a low priority search
was issued but was soon raised to high
priority after the above document was
found mobile task force eta 6 aka
awareness filters was formed to find SCP
1504
[Music]
addendum 1504 - one after being further
analyzed and sent through multiple
filters it was discovered that SCP 1504
s responses were different from what was
previously recorded the document has
been updated to include these responses
interviewed SCP 1504 interviewer dr.
Lloyd forward SCP 1504 is being
questioned on its background playing log
now what is your name ok now what year
were you born you wouldn't even notice
if I punched you in the nose thank you
for the year but do you have an exact
date hey watch this oh excuse me
my nose is bleeding I'm sorry that was
weird I've never been prone to random
nosebleeds it's because I [ __ ]
punches you maybe do you know why you
can't be heard I could say anything I
can do anything I could say and I'm
gonna rape and kill your wife you
wouldn't even notice Li I could actually
let them kill your wife you wouldn't
notice I'm living in a virtual hell
because I can die I'm gonna step outside
this room and take a cards cut I'm gonna
shoot myself with that gun and nothing
feels like in a room and we all ignore
you you know how I like this I want to
die that's fine thank you for your
cooperation with today's interview you
may return to your room okay this
concludes our lecture for today thank
you very much for listening if indeed
you still are and you were all dismissed
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to Andre Bichette Aundre chewy
aqui
I apologize if I'm pronouncing that
wrong Andre please get in touch if I
have Jax Merrick Pierce M Hamlin Austin
Thomas Aldridge Desmond Hoskins Depp's
McGee
dr. mortis Johnno Porter Judi Dench
Tiber ball I'm size 7 actual if you
would like a special thank you at the
end of each of my videos and some other
cool stuff as well visit patreon.com
forward slash the Volgin thank you
[Music]
you